المتحدثون الرسميون في اسرائيل ينقلون ما
يطلب منهم للراي العام الداخلي اما
المعلومات الدسمه عن الجلسات والاجتماعات
الامنيه فلن يجدها الاسرائيليون الا في
تقارير الصحافه العبريه لكن الصحافه
العبريه تعتمد في اغلب تقاريرها الهامه
على التسريبات لانها تعكس حقيقه الخلاف
بين اعضاء الحكومه ومجلس الحرب وتطرح
الاسئله اين التقصير من المسؤول اين
الاخفاق ما هي المشكله هذه التسريبات التي
تنشرها الصحف الاسرائيليه تزعج نتنياهو
كثيرا حتى انه وصفها بالوباء وقال انه لن
يستطيع الاستمرار على هذا الحال بحسب
وسائل اعلام محليه لذا طالب باخضاع وزرائه
والمسؤولين رفيعي المستوى الذين يحضرون
اجتماعات الحكومه ومجلس الحرب لاختبارات
كشف الكذب وامر رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
تساحي هنغبي ب بطرح مشروع قانون كشف الكذب
على الكنيست الاسرائيلي لاقراره لكن ما هو
التسريب الذي اغضب نتنياهو وجعله يتخذ هذه
الاجراءات القصه ان اربعه من وزراء
الحكومه هاجموا رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي هيرسي هاليفي بعد ان قرر تشكيل
فريق تحقيق لبحث الاخفاقات التي ادت الى
هجوم السابع من اكتوبر الماضي وتضمنت جلسه
الكابينه المصغر انتقادات ونقاشات غاضبه
بين بعض الوزراء ومسؤولين في الجيش بعد
هذه الجلسه
امتلعب حزب بني جانس عن حضور جلسه يوم
الاحد توقعوا ايضا ان مجلس وزراء الحرب لن
يدوم طويلا كيف علق الاسرائيليون على
اعتزام نتنياهو اختبارات الكذب او اجرائها
لكشف كذب الوزراء مايكي تقول التسريبات
جاءت من نتنياهو نفسه اذا وضعوه على جهاز
كشف الكذب مره واحده فمن المؤكد ان الجهاز
سيحترق من اكاذيبه مارون قال لك مارون
نتنياهو مهرج يخدع نفسه هو مجرد مجرم متهم
وضع دوله باكملها رهينه لحرب هرب من السجن
وخوفا من انتهاء حياته السياسيه مدري
نتنياهو مجرم الحرب يحاول تمرير قانون كشف
الكتب منذ عام 2018 لتشديد الرقابه فهو
يعمل بطريقه الديكتاتور تسريبات ثم غضب ثم
مطالبات باقرار قانون ليفعل ما يشاء دون
ان يتحرك احد جول يقول نتنياهو يستخدم
تسريباته هو واصدقائه لابتزاز الجيش
نتنياهو يشكل خطرا على وجودنا في اسرائيل
درور يقول رساله الى نتنياهو وحكومته
المجنونه لسنا مستعدين للاستمرار على هذا
النحو ايضا اترك مقعدك او
سنتركه اخي الاطلاعات الرائيه التي اجرتها
قناه كان الاسرائيليه اظهرت ان
64% من الاسرائيليين غير راضين عن اداء
نتنياهو في حربه على غزه وان حزب الليكود
لن يحصل على اكثر من 20 مقعدا في
الانتخابات القادمه